thank you all I can't believe people
actually came and it's actually listened
to me it wasn't really that long ago at
least in my head actually mathematically
it's almost 20 years since I was in this
particular class but actually in Turman
but that doesn't exist anymore taking
this class and taking classes from
Professor cosmic so Stanford has a quite
a bit of a impact in my career
especially the engineering school the
industrial engineering major and the
professor's I if I like work was here at
Stanford I want to give you guys a
little bit about my personal background
my belief is that the thoughts kind of
creates a picture eventually and the
personal part of who I am is much more
important than the professional part of
me I was born in Taiwan I lived the
first 10 years of my life in Taiwan and
then spent one year living in a little
island called Guam or I learned English
so yes English is my second language and
then I moved to start hoga which is
really about 15 minutes south of here
so the valley the bay area this is home
to me
I grew up here back in the day when I
was growing up I was Kiki as you can get
so me my friends would kind of ride our
bikes up and down the Enza and Steven
Stevens Creek I liked collecting
computer parts and kind of building our
own computers back then computers were
kind of a hobby right and today as we
sit here today you can't really separate
the business of what the computer
industry or technology industry really
is from kind of the passion for it and
one of the things I was want myself to
remember was back then before what a
dollar was what the DA was what grocery
was I cared about how fast my computer
were and all the programs I was
downloading and how fun it was to get a
hack at this little box that I was
building and that kind of passion should
always be with you guys really think
about all the interesting things that
you can build that you can become and
100 million euro or billionaires you
kind of build your business that you
can't really lose a piece of yourself
the passion
I was lucky enough to get in Stanford in
1994 I was an industrial engineering
major I graduated in 1998 not a lot of
you guys obviously remember who I was in
1998 but 1998 was the beginning of a
really really crazy period in the.com
history I know a lot of you sit here and
think about wow there must be a bubble
outside well 1998 was probably ten times
worse or better depending on kind of
your perspective when I was invited to
speak at this class the first thing I
did was I went online and looked at all
the videos because I was like what am I
really gonna talk about I'm kind of
mid-career I haven't been really done
too much so let me think about and
really figure out what other people are
talking about well I took a look at mug
shot covers video Jack Dorsey Larry Page
and Greeson must heal right and then I
felt started feeling really really tiny
I was like oh right these guys are
outliers right if you look at the
history of their career the first all
they consist I can start up the hitter
Jack can take home run I haven't hit the
home run yet and I try multiple times so
what am I versus what are these guys and
well I call them outliers as a
industrial engineering major I like to
distill everything down to math so I'll
put up a normal curve right all of you
guys here like I know the acceptance
right now for Stanford is like around 6%
right and assuming some sort of kind of
self selection into that pool I'll say
that whatever you think the x-axis might
be you guys are essentially between two
to three standard deviations on the mean
right so the top kind of 22.1%
of quote unquote the the general
population well these guys that was
speaking near standing here and talking
to you guys before there are between six
to seven standard deviation from the
mean what is that
when your mom tell you one in a million
well that means your 63rd deviation from
the mean when you're seven standard
deviation from the mean that means you
one out of billion so if you're in China
there's one of you the the industry that
I come from and all of you guys are
interested in kind of learning more
about have a term for for people or
things or companies are way outside I
mean that super successful that can
really kind of drive revolutionary
change they call them black swans by a
statistic that's interpret or they call
them unicorns I essentially impossibly
to find by eventually somehow in the
corner of your eye you see a one day
right so between one out of million and
one out of the billion well I had to
face the fact right and I am NOT a Black
Swan or nor I am a unicorn but what I am
is I don't give up I work hard I study
harder and I try and try again so this
story in this talk is about a guy who's
not a unicorn trying to do very unique
2010 of things and it's my my and my
hope is that every single one of you go
out and build 100 billion dollar
companies because I know that probably
exists in all of us right but that's not
necessarily gonna happen just
mathematically so what do we do how do
we really try to change the world from
that's the case so we want him back to
the story within 18 months of graduating
from Stanford so I graduated was 22 by
all time was 23 I started an Internet
company I was a combination of naive and
dumb all at the same time and that's
kind of a very dangerous combination my
first job out of Stanford was looking
for an MS of bank
I work for Kota Swiss for a guy named
Frank Cutrone I was one of his first and
was hired I did that job for about ten
months and I met a bunch of CEOs of
companies are trying to take public and
when you are naive you can't identify
talent when you see one
right so I was naive and and and kind of
stupid enough to think wow like these
CEOs they don't seem that smart I can do
this too so me plus two other guys from
the bank
quit ten months into the program and
decided started in in that company 1998
was a great time to start in a company I
had a deck and I was a banker so my deck
was really really beautiful so and
luckily for me I was from Stanford with
an engineering degree and happened to be
Asian so lots of VC likes to do pattern
matching so they go this guy must be
just as good as Jerry Yang so I said of
course actually my middle name is yay I
don't know why and I wouldn't give
myself that kind of money but in in
about in two years from starting the
company we raised about fifty million
dollars in total I didn't know how to
actually spend that money I was really
good at talking about a vision of what
the future can be with Bill Point and by
the way that's funny I never I always
skip this part
bill point is a marketplace for
commercial construction services and the
reason they always see us my mine is
actually because I actually had no
passion for that industry and it's
actually one of the biggest mistakes
I've made in my career which is picking
something I feel like there's a great
opportunity and therefore VC won't
invest rather than because I love what I
do right well I barely knew how to start
a company I barely knew how to design a
product I barely knew how to manage a
team and I was able to get some traction
and do some good stuff
in 1998 like Jeff basil like to say in
the land of the blind the one-eyed man
is king
so nobody realized I was blind because
everybody else was blind too so I was
able to raise a lot of money but the
world changed pretty quickly in 2001 the
market crashed and the world changed
dramatically the other direction however
business we could review actually came
out with an article and said in 2001
information technology doesn't matter
right this is the end of the technology
revolution just Larry Ellison that quote
is kind of disappearing on that slide
but what he essentially said was it was
in the middle of interview the world's
kind of cratering around around us and
he basically said that if he was 21 year
old he would not be in this business as
in and I believe for the next 1,000
years there will be no more revolution
around technology and that the platform
that we have today will continue to be
the same platform there will be no
longer any innovation in technology and
he recommends everyone that he talks to
to become a bioengineering or a doctor
my Biogen major doctor which is actually
yeah interesting for thought right like
that certainly is a future but of course
like I said the pendulum can swing one
direction or the other I was fired in
2001 by my board was my own company I
owned a significant majority of the
company at least in the common stock and
I was asked to leave I didn't know that
was actually possible right I didn't
know actually I didn't know the concept
of shares and percentage ownership and
comment versus preferred and the board
and the fiduciary duty of the board just
one day I walked into the office and it
told me hey we didn't want a 20-3 all
running a company with 30 million
dollars in the bank we wanted someone
with more gray hair maybe a VP from
Oracle to come and run this company that
we invested all this money in my initial
first thought like an immature 24
at the time 25 year old was at the time
was I'm gonna get all my buddies in the
engineering department I'm gonna go walk
out together and we just gonna disappear
and started in same company exactly the
same thing
Wow thank God I didn't do that right
because we all have responsibilities
there's 250 people working at build
point they all have families they have
cloud savings accounts they have mouths
to feed dinner to put on the table and
what a responsible thought I had and
what a responsible person I have I've
been to start a company without really
thinking through can I truly be
successful at building an Internet
company at the time I spent the next
year and a half of my life doing self
discovery so that's me in the red over
over in that picture actually it's not I
just found out on internet last night
but but you get the point it was a
combination of traveling the world
it was a combination of traveling the
world and trying to find myself and
spending a lot alone time and going to a
lot of parties because if you remember I
was 25 24 25 what do 24 25 year olds do
especially since I worked so hard before
that you think that I tell you guys the
moral of the story is hey as a 23 year
old don't quit your job don't quit your
job or don't leave Stanford and don't
get a job and just don't start a company
because you guys are not ready
well now that's not the case actually I
won't never say like because they are
guys out there like the door see that
Zuckerberg that gates the deals of the
world are outliers right there born to
start companies they have an inherent
knowledge or understanding of how to
navigate the travails the obstacle of
starting a company there they're just
geniuses right there's a Beethoven of
Mozart's of entrepreneurship right and
they know and in a lot of ways sitting
here today I wouldn't never be able to
figure out what I was or I wasn't right
so yes go chase your dream right but
very quickly understand that there are
things that tells you that you might not
be a jack dorsey or Mark Zuckerberg or
Bill Gates right and these are the
things I did I thought marketing was
open bar parties so I actually threw a
lot of parties I was an enterprise
software company throwing parties from
marketing right the mentality was
completely off if you guys think a lot
of these young entrepreneurs were overly
confident to the point of having lots of
hubris I was one of them I thought I was
better than everyone else I was 23 and
on paper worth tens of millions of
dollar right so why shouldn't I deserve
to drive a nice car and pretend that I'm
better than everyone else well there's a
very big difference between hubris and
confidence my confidence is the
willingness and the fearlessness of
solving a problem right the ability to
tackle a problem head-on without fear
hubris is the business the belief they
could solve a problem even with
tackling that actual they can be digging
deep and understanding the the
components of that problem and to be
serious for a second one of the most
important things I ever learned which I
do want to impart on this class is to
understand the concept of uni economics
right
I had a enterprise software product I
was giving away for free so here mr.
company take my product have it for free
I had a Salesforce I was paying about
$150,000 per salesperson to go sell the
product I was free I was advertising at
the San Jose arena with big billboards
at the Sharks shark tank right I
actually had ads and you guys do
probably don't remember red herring a
tech magazine like wired the the
customer segments the go to market
strategy the product itself the
component economics of how you become
powerful profitable was completely
misaligned right so if there's one thing
you learn is to really understand how
you're going to market and what the unit
economics of that and can you be
profitable on a per acquisition basis so
back to my life after some
self-discovery I decided that I'm not a
unicorn what I need to do is go back to
what my parents taught me which was work
harder than everyone else study harder
than everyone else and learn faster than
anyone else so I actually went to school
one I thought that hey Business School
could potentially give me the holes of
my education around how to start and
build an Internet company and that was
partially true right there's things that
you can certainly learn when you have
the hind side of what you did wrong the
other thing I did was actually I started
over this is a picture of nothing exact
you but my cue to look exactly like this
at eBay so I took a after Venis a co CEO
of an Internet company and worth tens of
millions of dollars and hunting 20 50
people work for me I decided to take an
entry-level job at eBay so I didn't even
have a title
I just truly entry-level and they were
paying me god I don't even remember it
was so little that I actually had to
borrow of money for my parents to
actually survive right and the rationale
there was it wasn't really about the
title or what my pay or the ability to
go to a cocktail party and give someone
a business card that says I'm the VP of
blah I just wanted to learn and I want
to go to the best place I can where
somebody had build a scalable internet
business and they must know something
right and therefore I can go to that
company and learn from the people there
expect the next 10 years of my life kind
of rebuilding a career one of the things
one of the goals I had was to go to the
multiple stages of an Internet company
or a technology company whether that is
new venture which I've done they're my
own company series a growth IPO and
fortune 100 I was lucky enough to
eventually ended up being a very senior
person at a very large technology
company called AT&T and we like to joke
that it's the desk dog so spending 10
years kind of climbing the corporate
ladder it's not what I will consider a
very entrepreneurial thing to do from
the superficial perspective but if you
understand your objective the things are
going to accomplish it's actually a very
and lightning experience and I'm gonna
tell you why building a company it's
very different than starting a company
right starting a company is selling a
vision its recruiting it is raising
money it is getting interviewed by
TechCrunch my building company is on
average of seven to ten year Road it is
hiring and firing it is managing a
product roadmap it's motivating setting
goals for iterating goals it's having
one on one that's it's looking up your
KPIs it's tracking your KPIs these are
very mundane and day-to-day things where
you need discipline and knowledge to do
and what I did in those 10 years was to
really a come accumulate skills and
experiences
and not titles right and I view that as
very important thing to do and then one
of the the most important thing that
happened in my career was the
realization that networking is actually
not about networking
it's about accumulating trust from
others one of the great examples I like
to give is at AT&T I was hired to kind
of build a division a new business unit
for AT&T and one of the hardest thing
you have to do is when you're given a
task your job does try to fill out and
find people smarter than you to kind of
solve that problem with you and I went
back to my days at eBay right I was very
junior employee at a new Bay but I
worked hard I was smart I was
collaborative and I built a great
reputation well good enough reputation
so I went back to eBay and found as many
people as I can to come and work with me
at eBay there were more senior than me
got paid more than me but they were
willing to come to AT&T because they
understood that the value of what we can
accomplish together it's not really
about the title or the hierarchy it's
about the accomplishments itself and the
last thing I would say about how do you
really spend that time building a career
that 10 years of your life is how do you
really accumulate experiences iterations
right it's not about the 10 years
actually or the 2 years of the 3 years
it's really about how many times you can
get another bat right how many times can
you iterate and learn and repeat go to
companies that let you learn and repeat
release as many product into the
marketplace as possible launch as many
marketing campaign as possible I
understand the feedback loop between
your customers and the feature set all
the things that get you to understand
hey but that wouldn't work if I did that
again but this will work and I better
try it one more time so what happened in
the ten years since I was in the game
Ryan I spent 10 years kind of building a
career working at large companies and
I'm not really thinking too hard about
the entrepreneur side of that equation
or my passion
you guys might be too young
Michael join playing baseball if you
guys don't remember he's been I think
two years playing baseball rather than
playing basketball the valley in 2014 is
very different than the one I graduated
into when I graduated from Stanford the
cost of starting a business is
dramatically different right pets.com
raised 50 million dollars it's just to
get website up at Bill point we needed
to get a bunch of Solaris boxes so
that's quarter-million dollars
right Elco 8i license for the database
and another quarter million dollars
ba app server another quarter million
dollars and then a web server from
Netscape just to be able to print hello
world on the browser somewhere right
that's million and half to two million
dollar just to get started today I can
go build pits calm in 15 minutes right
after this class through a share hosting
account I probably cost me five dollars
a month right that's a dramatic
difference in the cost of starting a
business right so what does that mean
well that means that anyone here can
actually go and start a company and all
of you guys are probably thinking of it
and lots of people are doing it right no
longer do you have to go to sin Hill
Road and beg for four million dollars
before getting something off the ground
you can do that here this instant my
five minutes from those class ends you
can go and start a company and really
figure out where this product market fit
between your concept and the customer
that you're targeting the other thing
that happened was the funds actually
survived the dot-com boom were actually
successful so they were able to raise
more and more and more money so these
venture funds went from having a hundred
million dollars in the management to
having five hundred a billion two
billion dollar and imagine right it
takes five dollars on a company yet
these venture funds need to deploy
millions of dollars two to ten million
dollars to make it worth their while
maker returns so all of a sudden there's
a huge funding gap between the guy that
says hey takes me five dollars so
starting in that company maybe I need to
fire four engineers so pay them a
hundred thousand dollars in each so
maybe I need five thousand to a million
dollars to get
now a company off the ground for about a
year well it's not not very interesting
to these venture funds the good news is
that at the same time a lot of the major
Internet company are starting to go
through a cycle or the original
employees origin a founder is kind of
leaving these companies and trying to
figure out what to do what they brought
with them was a an experience and
expertise that can bring to the rest of
the community and we hear about this all
time the the Facebook mafia the Google
mafia or the PayPal mafia right what
this guy brought to the table was hey
you want to start a company and used to
work at PayPal come over to my house
let's go through the business plan and
figure out whether there's something
here and there is I'll be an advisor and
help you out right and that's the start
of this culture of kind of paying it
forward and the forth and equally
important thing was these guys started
out with just offering their advice and
they started saying hey I've made ten
fifteen fifteen million dollars in my
last startup why don't I help you out
and give you two hundred K three hundred
okay 400 K and they became in this
robust angel community that kind of
really built around the value that never
really existed when I was trying to
starter in in my company and in that
community grew pretty much from being an
angel a semi-professional basis to
actually a professionally managed and a
venture fund ecosystem they're called
seed funds now right and you guys
probably have heard of guys like
baseline venture and Harrison middle and
first-round a lot of these guys came
from the companies that we all have
heard of and now they're actually acting
like professional angel investors full
time investing looking in businesses and
trying to deploy capital for their
limited partners and they're able to
manage these small funds right they
usually have between 30 to 100 million
dollars and they can give away 250 K
100k or 500 K to an entrepreneur and
really make it then in their returns so
at the same time the bigger VCS have
moved up the value chain while this
vacuum has created a whole new
generation of venture funds these guys I
call them kind of entrepreneurial run
venture funds and it typically operators
and entrepreneurs
a venture fund and their perspective is
not financial their perspectives
operational and creates a very different
type of incentive and decision-making
the result of these kind of four major
changes in the ecosystem created kind of
ripples right the democratization and
the moral normalization entrepreneurship
who now is graduating from Stanford been
an entrepreneur wasn't really a career
path
he was an aspiration right we I've heard
about Jerry Yang I've heard about Bill
Gates I wanna be like them but it wasn't
a career path right everybody still did
the banking the consulting or whatever
the thing that they wanted to do to kind
of prove themselves as having a great
degree here at Stanford well today being
an entrepreneur is actually a career
path right you can with your mom and dad
and I and say hey I'm not gonna go work
for Google I'm gonna start my internet
company
they'll probably freak out a little bit
but eventually they're like okay I've
heard about this is actually a viable
career path it's something that you can
actually do the other thing that
happened was the near fishing the
sharing of kind of knowledge and
information the blogs the fact that
everybody is involved in this community
the pace of conversation they all
created this environment where
information is almost free by in a sense
that a reputation of a of a VC or how a
company we started getting scale all
those things are now you can actually
learn about right in 1999 if I want to
figure out what's the secret sauce for
some other Internet company I gotta beat
my way to that CEO store and really beg
them for that information
today that information is much more
faster like I said there's tons of
access to capital at multiple stages
right so that means if you want 50k you
can get 50k for 150 million dollars you
can get 50 million dollars that wasn't
the case back in the day right if you
want to raise money you gotta go fund
someone that can give you four million
dollars at a time
if you don't need four million dollars
tough luck
and then really this this idea that VCS
are not a super class of people right
that they're just like you and I and
it's a fair exchange
equity for money and they're here to be
part of the ecosystem contribute to the
success of the companies like guys like
Fred Wilson and Dave hornik black filled
really create this environment of hey
that's open kimono about what exactly we
do and how we make our decisions and
that to make entrepreneurs choose us
rather than us choose entrepreneurs I
like to think that the ultimate outcome
and this is perhaps a little bit of a
cultural statement the controversial
statement is that entrepreneurship has
become math right and I don't mean that
it's it's completely certain I mean that
it's a it's a series of stochastic
independent mathematical events from the
VC perspective or the macro perspective
entrepreneurship or new venture is
almost like evolution or Darwinism right
ie the way to find success is to have
multiple mutations right and the more
you mutations you have the higher
potential for success right so the
mutation in themselves isn't a a thought
process or design to be better or worse
it's simply because you have multiple
mutations that success appears right so
if you have ten startups in a particular
ecosystem the chances of one of them
becoming a snapchat it's gonna be much
lower than if you have 10,000 startups
and one of them becoming a snapchat
right the reverse of that which is
actually more important for all you guys
in this room is that now you can view
entrepreneurship like a baseball game
right and I have Pete Rose up there not
because I condone cheating or gambling I
don't lots of you guys think of him as
the lifetime leader in hits in in
professional baseball the actually more
impressive thing is the lifetime leader
by almost 20% for at-bats right and it
is not it doesn't have us a
significantly above average batting
average right the reason that he's
successful is he got a lot of at-bats
and that's what all of you guys have to
really think about is guys like
Zuckerberg Bill Gates right those guys
were hit 400 right there and natural and
natural they're just really good at
hitting a baseball how do you become
successful when you're just an average
dude who hits 260
well the way you'd be successful is you
get a lot of hurt that's right so on my
VC perspective where I make a lot of
investment these days that I work with
entrepreneurs a much rather bet on
entrepreneur that has 10 of bats with a
low batting average than a entrepreneur
with a high average and only a couple of
bats right and the reason is because all
we really care about is getting a single
hit right I really don't care about how
many times you try to be successful I
care about that eventually that you are
so the speed in which you get those are
bad is important right so if you have an
idea about business how do you iterate
fast enough so that you can actually
become successful and the number of
times so you can actually start new
businesses and matters as well so the
changes in the ecosystem have created an
environment where you actually don't
have to be a unicorn well actually spend
10 years like I did relearning the
muscle memories of how to build a great
company to become a successful
entrepreneur I'm not saying that all of
you will go out there and build
billion-dollar companies if you follow
the formula you're not right there's
still those huge companies I reserve for
those who are relief born with the
instinct and they inherent kind of
knowledge to do it I'm saying that we
can all do interestings in our life we
can all change the world maybe it's one
little niche maybe it's one little
segment maybe it's not a billion dollar
exit but we can all make a difference if
we really think about our lives as
multiple paths really leverage the the
community and the resources that's
really around us I do want to switch
gear a little bit and talk about what
I'm actually doing it in LA I moved in
LA in 2006
for personal reasons and what Los
Angeles is today or two years ago when I
started my collab was what the barrier
was in 2007 which is really before the
advent of seed funds that the
organization of entrepreneurship of this
kind of understanding of
entrepreneurship as a playbook rather
than this mythical black box what's
interesting about la is that la has all
the major components of being a great
ecosystem and for me the most important
units of measure are the most important
commodity for any community is the
number of Engineers right engineers are
what fuels the the fire to really drive
the innovation cycle and in LA although
none of them are as good at Stanford
with there are schools like USC and UCLA
and Caltech that I really world me now
an engineering school is kind of
producing great talent at building great
code but we what la didn't have was this
ability to bring all the pieces together
to create a petri dish when an
environment can really increase the
probability of successful entrepreneurs
and that's what macula is I wanted to
bring la the the all the trappings of
the ecosystem that we have here all the
benefits all the people all the thought
processes all the culture and bring to
LA and really create a way for la
entrepreneur to be successful how do we
play level the playing field we have a
big loss of mentors people that I work
with in again think about the network
right lots of people I work with here in
Silicon Valley as mentors for our
companies acting as advisors people to
bounce ideas off people to kind of keep
them in the driving rain as they really
kind of coup in their head of this this
entrepreneurship road given my partner
in my act and in the fact my partner and
myself spent a lot on them in the
barrier we actually have access to a lot
of the same seed funds and the same kind
in venture capital funds that
entrepreneurs never traditionally never
had access to and probably I like to
think one of the most important thing is
my partners and I work with these
entrepreneurs to help them build their
businesses I spent 10 years
getting beat up there's not a lot of
replacement for that kind of knowledge
and I can save our entrepreneurs a lot
of time and a lot of headache I
compressed that ten years into one or
two years of learning within the
confines of my collab and help them
build their business a muckle app I like
to tell entrepreneurs that you don't
have to be a unicorn to build a unicorn
right and how do I extrapolate to the
guys to all you guys here in this room
and the the way that I played it is a
seller ears are great but they're really
for people who are kind of lazy right
all of you here can go find the right
mentors the right advisors to find your
network to find the VCS to really kind
of build your business right if you
understand there's a bunch of words down
there that's nationally but I just
talked to it if you understand a few
things about being an entrepreneur you
can actually be quite successful without
being a unicorn or actually spending ten
years building a kind of building your
career have a really long view right the
average company is between seven to ten
years and that means whether you're
really successful today with a
TechCrunch is writing about you today
whether you think it was 10 million 100
million or a billion dollars all that
can change in seven years lots of lots
of stuff can change so have a really
long view around who you are where do
you want to get to for you personally
and for the company and build a business
that really matches your passion and not
matches your vision the other thing to
look at is be confident like I said
before be confident but really trust the
instinct of those around you surround
yourself with executives that perhaps
they're not entrepreneurs but they
really know how to do one thing right
right you don't have all the answers and
there's lots of people that's a lot more
smarter than you that can really help
you become successful and share the
credit once you are there so last thing
go be a unicorn thank you
okay so now I'll have an opportunity to
ask some questions I'm gonna start
throwing out the first question to you
and then I hope all of you in the
audience will think about type of
questions that you would like to ask so
let's imagine that I got accepted into
your accelerator tell us a little about
what that experience might be sure how
long would I be there what's in our
services what I have yes I've been
trying really hard not to kind of Mark
it and talk too much about mucker
because not all you guys need us but I'm
happy to talk about it
the Mokka life program is a sixth
romance program and the reason that
there's a huge variable is because we
don't believe there's a formula to
success we believe the formula to
success is actually the iteration and
the experimentation of getting to a
product market fit so a company come
joins the program they actually work out
of the office and I insert myself as
part of the management team my partners
and I and we actually help our companies
build the product take it to market test
different go to market strategies and
try to understand if the dog will eat
the dog food
whether that whether that means lots of
people using the sites that means
hundreds of thousand dollars in revenue
or huge engagement metrics whatever it
might be our job is to help our
companies get to that mythical product
market fit and then at the end of that
process help them fundraise with venture
capitalists great questions Teddy
sectors you focus on and why and this
your location and all I have to do
anything with the kinds of sectors that
you look at cuz Elaine has a different
business spelling obviously so the
answer is yes
the the foundational way that we look at
companies is can my partners and I add
value to the entrepreneur we look at the
Delta between when they join the program
and the projected Delta when they leave
the program
can we add enough value for that company
to feel like they got enough how are you
working with us and given that type of
thought process it generally means that
if I don't have a personal experience in
that sector it actually doesn't make
sense for us to work with that company
even if I believe that's a billion
dollar company where
to happen right because again it's a
cottage industry I want to work on
something I'm passionate about that the
entrepreneur is actually passionate
about an action I can actually add value
the good news is that my partner and I
had a little bit of a career a DD so we
have done quite a lot of different
things when it comes to the landscape of
Internet industries and segments so that
means things like e-commerce
marketplaces SAS security content and
media in your way these are all the
things that we have experiences running
and we know how to build those
businesses great questions yes more
about your experience at AT&T
interactive in such a large company it
must have been difficult to get things
moving to get support and maintain
support for your initiatives happy to do
it
ironically the ability to sell and
recruit was the most important part of
being successful at a very very large
company and at a company like AT&T who
are there's multiple stakeholders or
there's maybe about 500 people in my
same level the key to success is to
actually gain allies and the way do you
go allies I understand people's
motivations and we like here to think
that Bing companies are not innovative
and they're slow and they're like
dinosaurs and the people I like to play
politics well that's actually not
completely true I mean we all have one
life to live right we all want to do
interesting things or even great things
with our lives and that means that guy
that works at AT&T or that guy that's
behind the checkout counter at Safeway -
you and I sitting here in this room
everybody have a motivation that drives
them right so if you understand the
motivation and how they want to be
different and how they want to change
the world you can actually help them
accomplish that that that goal the same
thing that AT&T if you've got enough
allies and have enough people that
subscribe to your region you can get a
lot done right because every company
needs to grow and everybody want to be
innovated great
yes Oh week okay people explain now why
he decided to join the tech stars
Network and how Microlock the first
project starts okay the question is why
did we decide to start the text join the
textile Network and how we're different
than the other textile program we wanted
a couple things and I think I've never
won an accelerator in my whole life
right I started companies I worked at
different internet companies at
different stages I worked at large
telecom companies like AT&T and I was
eating my own dog food I listen to my
own medicine which is if I don't know
how to do something don't be afraid go
do it
but surround yourself with people to
actually know what they're doing and get
their advice and what text I did was
actually provide us with a playbook a
way to kind of jumpstart and really
think about how we can add value and run
a great accelerator
the second part of the question is why
we're different be in Los Angeles where
we are ace in the technology epsilon
second tier city where the ecosystems
not a robust were the Capitals not as
efficient the way to be successful is
actually to be more focused on the
outcome right so a typical text our
program will be three months and you go
through the program and they have a very
specific cookbook to go through and once
our end of the program you go out and
fundraise our program can literally last
two years if you can't find product
market state or whatever your initial
ideas doesn't work you continue to pivot
right well no look we will not let
entrepreneurs pivot in the wind right
and that means we will now push them out
the door and let them figure it out on
their own right our job is to help
entrepreneurs and every entrepreneurs
dream deserve the chance to be
successful right our job is not to have
a tea company into class and pick the
one that or be lucky enough to pick one
that becomes successful
our job is to be a hundred percent
referenceable with every entrepreneur we
work with and that means every
entrepreneur we will work with them
until they give up right and
long as they're at it then we will be
working with them great yes not being
rude just curious why should I move to
miss Angeles if I'm in LA if I could
find better engineers here they would
rather work in a garage they're working
you should hey what's the second Valley
or the Bay Area or human Palo Alto or
soma is a very unique place if you are
lucky enough to stay here to be from
this area to to pursue your passion here
in Silicon Valley you should stay here
the the chance of success here will be
infinitely higher than anywhere in the
world but if you happen to have a family
and Los Angeles if you happen to love
the Sun we've happened to love the beach
if you happen to just want to be Los
Angeles because you have a dream to one
day become a great director go pursue
your dreams and then if you one day you
happen to want to start an Internet
company and you don't want to move my
collab is a great choice for you right
we level the playing field but if you're
here then say it's like question what
size of the company that you're let's
say letting in let if the company is
profitable you accept them to the
accelerator yeah because the way we work
with the companies also hands on and so
customized and the stages of our
companies are actually significantly
different than other accelerators we
definitely take companies where it's
three guys with an idea on a piece of
piece of napkin and we help them get
that going there are times we take
companies that's three years old our
most the largest company we've ever
taken from the employee perspective is
15 from the fundraising perspective they
already have a million 1/2 raised from
the longest perspective as 3 years right
again what we looked at is the Delta in
which we can help accelerate their
business and how much value we can add a
lot of these companies are going through
kind of huge strategic shift or the
market is going through significant
changes and we can be of value
for an interesting and adult so that is
for our most recent investment we have a
company that actually moved from China
there are a company that's three years
old they were selling a premium app in
the App Store doing about a million
downloads a year and then wanted to
create a larger business it was a great
cash flow business and they were making
good money but they were thinking about
how do I really change the world and we
help them tip it to a different
completely different model and can gain
scale and reach that the neighbors are
possible so it really depends on what
your goals are and how we can get you
there all on the stage obviously if your
square or one of these ladies of stage
companies it would make a lot of sense
but any early-stage company that's still
looking for product market fit we can
help
do you take equity in the companies we
do we take between six to eight percent
of the company and we make investments
between 25k all the way to fund okay at
some point in the future right
other questions yes so from the mucker
laugh perspective about sixty percent of
our company's consumer focus and forty
percent is enterprise and ironically if
you actually look at the GDP that split
is about the same right we are not a
index fund so that means I my goal is
actually not to match what's going on in
the marketplace I want to find great
entrepreneurs targeting on a white space
opportunity with a disruptive idea if
that means all ten companies that I work
with right now as consumers so be it
that means all tense Enterprise so be it
it's really about the opportunity itself
we're very bottom up in their approach
rather than very top-down great question
is why you start your first company
so I was just curious whether you
pick up anything that was useful to be
doing your Henriques at Christmas or if
your particular and careers that you
think would be useful for people who
actually want to start a business yeah
it's very important to have some some
basic financial skills and I learned
that working as an investment banker it
doesn't mean you can't pick that up
taking a class here or going online or
taking a book right taking a book and
just reading the key years to accumulate
applicable skills and applying to the
business that you're working on that
could be working at a job that could be
you know chasing down professor cosmic
in the hall and asking a few questions
take any opportunity to accumulate
knowledge so that doesn't mean that's
working at a certain industry matters or
not matters there's a lot of ways to
build knowledge that doesn't require you
to actually commit one or two years of
your life doing something right but I
will say that no matter what job you do
to be successful the discipline and the
the depth of commitment you need to be
to be successful at that job it's
something that is transferred
transferable to anything that you do so
there's always something you can learn
no matter what job you're in they help
you become successful in the future so
be cognizant work hard and and really
think hard about what you're doing right
now today and how that really helps you
in the future so let me build on this
let's go back to when you were a student
here mm-hmm
what would you have done differently
when you were students to prepare you
for your first venture is there
something you could have done
differently and also how much can you
actually learn in a classroom setting
versus the real-life experience that
you've gotten all these ventures
I think classrooms gives you a framework
to understand the problem then you're
facing what it doesn't do is help you
actually create the solution to that
problem but I always like to believe the
the process
much more important than the outcome
right how you arrive at a solution it's
much more important of a solution itself
and that's what Stanford and in
education provides you with that also
means that the muscle memories of
applying a framework to a problem you're
facing in your life is something that
can only be accumulated in real life
right but that doesn't mean that sitting
here at Stanford that you can actually
go and launch a product and try to
figure out product market fit sell
something build something or or or come
up with an idea and really test your
ability to figure out whether something
you learned in class X can actually be
helpful in doing Y one of the things I
wish done more is actually go out and
actually do it right of course back in
1999 for me to go to web site cost me
two million dollars so couldn't even if
I wanted to
you guys have an incredible opportunity
to actually go out and do and turn your
dreams actual reality or concept into
actual product and the cost of that is
almost nothing especially given the
resources that's available here so go
take advantage of it right I don't
believe any of the Stanford work Lobo
was so overwhelming you that you can't
actually pursue the things that actually
drive your passion so great question yes
you said that we tend to take man you
said that you take a a managing part in
the companies and you actually are hands
on managing which seems to be a little
different from a lot of other
accelerators what was your reasoning for
doing my reason is because from the
outside in I wanted to create a program
where I'm fully invested in success of
every single entrepreneur I'm working
with right and that means I gotta be a
coach rather than just be a some guy
that actually just manages the program
right and to really ensure the success I
gotta bring my experiences to bear to
these companies and that's really truly
the only way to do it the other the
other
the way that we structured the program
is because again this is Los Angeles
right so that means the entrepreneurs
over scene have great potential for for
being a great entrepreneur but they just
don't have the muscle memory or the
knowledge or the experiences that all of
you are lucky to have here by being in
in Palo Alto right so us working with
them more hands-on just helps them train
them faster to become what we need them
to become which is a certain type of
great entrepreneur so given your your
stint at credit Swiss what's your
perspective on why banks have such a
hard time later baby
well the caveat there is I spend ten
months there so I can consider myself an
expert in banking but I have cut both
pieces one is regulatory right and
everything in the bank is touches some
sort of regulatory body and laws are
always swell to change and so therefore
innovation runs up against a movable
object is always hard to execute the
other is really around the fact that
banks work with virtual goods if you
will right that's kind of a weird
statement to say well money is a virtual
good right most of the money in the
world is actually not in hard cash right
so that means it's very intangible right
ten million dollars is just a number on
a spreadsheet my billion dollars another
number on the spreadsheet
it's really hard for banking companies
to really think about the concreteness
of the innovation and the thing that the
product itself that they can take to
market they think of themselves as
services a services company providing a
number crunching rather than providing
innovative products like it's easier to
innovate on something much more concrete
than just a PowerPoint presentation
bunch of numbers number crunching some
analysis to give so much in Atma core
lab is their interaction between the DIF
ventures that are working there is there
opportunity for cross-pollination
absolutely
we the and any given time there's about
ten companies working on market lab and
they're physically working in office
right so there's not 80 companies spread
across kind of Mountain View but
literally in the office every single day
and like I said to our companies
leverage the resources around them
experiences and the knowledge right and
my partners and I are obviously one one
kind of vector into achieving that goal
and the people that they're working with
that they see eye to eye was across the
cube across the desk these are also
other people that they they can gain you
know a network or solve a problem for
them so a lot of our companies end up in
each other's customers they help each
other recruit other engineers or other
potential employees and sometimes end up
becoming visors for each other right no
one is smarter than someone else and
tears are actually great ways to kind of
bounce ideas off each other great one
final question yes I've gone through
multiple transformations in your life
and work through so many different
companies I just was wondering like when
starting this new company like coming
out at 22 what were your goals coming
out of Stanford what are your goals now
and what's next can you please repeat
that so it's a multiple stage question
so the the question would be what was my
goal
what what I wish to accomplish when I
first graduated from Stanford and what's
my goal and objective right now right
right so when I first graduated from
Stanford I had two objectives one was to
do something great right which is kind
of generic it's part of the reason I
failed I wasn't very specific round one
I want to do another thing which I am
actually ashamed to say is I want to
make a lot of money today that's
certainly important right I want to send
my kids to Stanford
it's really expensive here right but it
is a sight product of what I want to
accomplish rather than the main outcome
right and that speaks to what do I want
to do after spending three years at AT&T
I quickly realized that my passion was
still around this community I grew up
with here in the Bay Area right it is it
is Apple in Cupertino HP in Palo Alto
being one of the the epicenter of
starting to change the world one bits
and bytes at a time and I wanted to do
that again but I thought that it would
be very selfish of me to just start a
company on my own and go through the
thing that I wanted it to do that at
this point my career I have some
flexibility I've saved up and actually
have a safety net in the fact that I
have a a nice career so I can go do
whatever I want to do eventually
so my collab and then making investments
and kind of see stage companies in LA
it's my way of giving back I realized
that the path I've taken is certainly as
one path for success but if I can help
someone actually shortcut that process
and become successful and achieve their
dreams I can actually get just as much
utility or benefit or a sense of
accomplishment doing that the question
is then what's will sue gonna do ten
years from now well I don't know no
that's that's kind of the the the hard
question everybody has to answer I love
what I'm doing now it's something that
we've been really successful at doing
and and I've never enjoy a better more
fulfilling job than I'm doing now
helping other people become successful
is actually more fulfilling and making
yourself successful it's is actually one
of the biggest revelations of the last
two years and if I'm lucky enough where
the returns are great and entrepreneurs
love continuing love working with us
maybe I'll do this for the rest of my
life thing
for those that can't do maybe they'll
teach and isn't my way of teaching
wonderful join me in thanking will for
his wonderful
you